foreign
[Music]
this is the time when parliament really
has to assert its leadership in sri
lanka i think the opposition has to step
up to the plate nominate someone to be
president and prime minister and
parliament must agree to that in the
interim
the constitution provides that the
speaker will be in charge an acting
president until a new president and
prime minister are appointed
there's also been a call for abolishing
the executive presidency the
concentration of so much power in one
individual so hopefully they will elect
someone with the agreement that it would
only be a symbolic uh president until a
such time that constitutional changes
can be brought for them to abolish the
executive presidency
[Music]
i think the most important thing for sri
lanka now is stability and credibility
the discussions with imf are ongoing
alleviating the problems of the country
fully is a process that will take at
least a year
but in the interim bringing confidence
and trust in the government alone can
unlock bridge financing
and support for sri lanka that can
reduce the shortages that are causing
extreme pain and difficulty for society
[Music]
the crucial need now is the supply of
fuel and medicines and food in
particular we are facing a food crisis
this is not the time for economic
reforms you would have to get a fresh
mandate with the new government before
we can go for economic reforms
immediately there can't be any more
austerity people should be given relief
to be able to survive my economy could
be shrinking as much as by a tenth this
year so it's a very dire situation
[Music]